china realiza un hallazgo de unos 90
millones de años un grupo de
paleontólogos descubrió los restos de
una especie gigantesca de un dinosaurio
herbívoro de cuello largo en la región
de la Patagonia al sur del país siendo
una de las bestias más grandes jamás
descubiertas el chucarosaurus medía
cerca de 30 metros de largo esto lo
sabemos gracias a los restos que pudimos
encontrar de este de este dinosaurio que
incluyen partes de el miembro anterior
del de la mano digamos de este animal
como del miembro posterior y algunos
elementos de la cadera
Es llamativo realmente el tamaño de este
animal que el hueso del fémur el hueso
que articula la cadera con con el pie
mide más de un metro 90 de alto el
hallazgo en la reserva natural pueblo
blanco sucedió en 2018 y recientemente
fue terminada la investigación
paleontológica chucarosaurios
diripiendas significa El lagarto fuerte
y revuelto y habría vivido durante la
época del cretácico superior junto
depredadores peces y tortugas marinas la
Patagonia fue el hogar de gigantescos
dinosaurios como el colosal patagotitan
mayorum el más grande descubierto hasta
ahora en el mundo Argentina tiene una
una cuestión muy positiva para nosotros
somos paleontólogos de que es uno es el
paraíso de la paleontología porque debes
en la actualidad debemos tener más de
140 especies Y eso nos ubica por lo
menos en el top 3 del mundo ahora los
restos del Dinosaurio serán expuestos al
público en la provincia de Río negro